Facebook versus conservatives it's a
theme we discussed last night with
internet stars diamond and silk who did
get some good press today and it came up
on Capitol Hill during senator Ted
Cruz's questioning of Facebook CEO Mark
Zuckerberg Gizmodo reported that
Facebook had purposely and routinely
suppressed conservative stories from
trending news has blocked a post of Fox
News reporter has blocked over two dozen
Catholic pages and most recently blocked
Trump supporters diamond and silks page
with 1.2 million Facebook followers
after determining their content and
brand were quote unsafe to the community
are you aware of any ad or page that has
been taken down from Planned Parenthood
senator I'm not but let me just dive on
org sorry how about moveon.org I'm not
specifically aware of those about any
Democratic candidate for office I'm not
specifically aware I mean I've I'm not
I'm not sure joining me now for reaction
is the American spectators Jeffrey Lord
continuing our defending the first
segment Jeffrey I thought that was a
great exchange he actually went on to
say that he is cuz he is concerned
because Silicon Valley is very left and
he said it's it's it's a left-of-centre
they a place and that's just what it is
and so he said we're very concerned
about protecting and in allowing all
voices on the Facebook forum but he
didn't really have a good answer to Cruz
who he kind of met his match with Ted
Cruz about all these voices that are
having trouble being heard what was your
reaction to that exchange well this is
what concerns me I mean someone else on
that panel asked him whether or not he
could discuss the political leanings of
his employees and he said something they
affected well he doesn't check them
the point is Laura he doesn't have to
check them he's dealing he's getting his
employees from a pool of people that he
extreme he himself says are extremely
left-leaning that's what's going to
happen here and you know Lorelei
- laughs this is the same argument that
I was hearing when I was a teenager from
people like Spiro Agnew except it was
about the technology of the day which
was CBS ABC and NBC it is the same
precise argument today except we're
dealing with Facebook or Google or
Twitter or what-have-you
it doesn't change what we're dealing
with here are people who have a liberal
bias and they I mean diamond and silk I
could not believe that I mean I know
diamond and silk they're fabulous people
the notion that they are unsafe for the
community I mean this is crazy but
that's the way the liberal mind works
and that's what you get when they how do
we deal with it yeah exactly we're gonna
get to that in a second but when they
say community they mean the liberal
community they're offensive and unsaved
right to the left-wing mindset that
dominates in Silicon Valley and through
most of California and so they are very
concerned about that and they're very
concerned about it catching on through
perhaps increasing popularity of
President Trump and again Zuckerberg
obviously obviously is a really smart
guy but he did not have good answers
when it came to those questions of why
are these examples of conservative
organizations Ted Cruz rattled them all
off not getting adequate that's a
response on Facebook when they're like
whether followers are not getting their
notices why is that happening
Facebook always gives some mumbo-jumbo
and you don't get it you don't get a
good response right and we need to be
candid here in the case of diamond and
silk if they were African American women
who were liberal no one at Facebook
would have blinked when they posted
something that looked at African
American women who loved Donald Trump
uh-uh that's not supposed to happen and
so therefore they've got to be curved
that's the real problem here so what do
what do conservatives do Jeffrey again
we're concerned about defending free
expression freedom of conscience the
First Amendment these corporations are
so big they're like many governments
they can control they can just keep out
so what do conservatives do what do they
just stop using Facebook do just d-list
on Facebook
you know III hate to go that route here
I mean I just instinctively don't like
this kind of thing the boycotts in all
of this and I spoke to an advertiser who
was boycotted several years ago by
people who didn't like rush limbaugh and
he said to me this was not a boycott
this was an organized terror campaign
his life was threatened his business was
threatened his employees were harassed
but if conservatives want to be part of
the social media just stick to social
media they want to be part of the social
media which is important for connecting
with friends or advancing you know your
product lines or whatever it then the
Facebook is still really really
important so his Instagram so was you
know a snapchat and while the other
means of communication I mean so what do
you do right he got a question today
about who was his competition and of
course effectively the answer was the
other have any I would certainly hope
that there are conservatives out there
who are young and enterprising and
entrepreneurial minded to challenge this
I mean that certainly can be done over
time but other than that at the moment I
think that your series here on defending
the first is excellent we have got to
publicize this get the word out how
there's whether it's on television or
the internet or in print and let people
know how this game is working because
it's not a good one
and I think that's right and let's take
Zuckerberg at his word he wants all
voices to be heard he wants the
community to be you know their
information to be okay take you at your
word now let's see the proof Jeffery
thanks so much